[موسيقى]
اللوفر متحف اسطوري وهو الاكبر في اوروبا
ياخذ الزائر في رحله عبر الزمن من خلال 38
الف قطعه فنيه معروضه من ضمنها بعض رئ
التراث العالمي مثل تمثال فينس د ميلو او
لوحه الحريه تقود الشعب لاجين
دلاك لكشف اسرار متحف اللوفر علينا ان
نبتعد عن القاعات التي تضج ب 30 الف زائر
يوميا ونمر بالمستودع الذي يضم كنزا لا
يقدر
بثمن كل ثلاثاء حين تغلق ابواب المتحف يتم
نقل الاعمال من جناح الى اخر تحت انظار
امين قسم
النحت
هذا يحمل نوعا من الخطوره ومن التوتر في
كل مره ننقل فيها عملا من موضعه نكون
حذرين
للغايه المتحكمون في هذه اللعبه هم العمال
الذين ينقلون هذه الاعمال لتاخذ المكان
المخصص لها في التظاهرات
المختلفه الحركات محسوبه بدقه مخافه اتلاف
القطع
النادره
كل يوم ثلاثاء ننتقل بين اقسام المتحف
لتغيير مكان التماثيل لقد تدربنا على
النحت وهذا يمكننا من فهم ابعاد المنحوتات
ومدى
هشاشتها الحب هو اسم هذه المنحوته
الرخاميه لجاك سالي تقدر قيمتها ب 5
ملايين يورو وكانت المنحوته المفضله لدى
الماركيز د بومبادور التي اثرت بشكل كبير
في النواحي الثقافيه والفنيه والسياسيه في
البلاط الفرنسي وكانت عشيقه الويس الخام
عشر هنا تحت احدى قاعات المتحف تم تكليف
بعض النجارين المهاره باعاده تهيئه وترميم
الاثاث القديم هل العمل في اللوفر
ممتع انه لشرف لي هذا ينير
الذهن النا واسافر بخيالي
باستمرار يعمل هذا الفريق في احدى الورشات
ال 14 المخصصه لاعاده ترميم وتهيئه القطع
القديمه التي تعرضت
للتلف كان لدينا تمثال نصفي اضطرنا الى
ازالته لان قاعدته غير ثابته جئنا به الى
الورشه لصناعه قاعده جديده له هذا رائع
شرف لنا ان نلمس هذه الاعمال
هل تخافون من الحاق الضرر بهذه
القطعه نفكر في ذلك باستمرار لكن ينبغي ان
نكون واثقين من
انفسنا انه سحر التمويه والخداع البصري
فلا احد يلاحظ ان بعض قواعد هذه التماثيل
ليست من الرخام الاصلي مثل قاعده تمثال
فينس د ميلو في قسم الاثار الاغريقيه الذي
عثر عليه في جزيره ميلوس عام 18
بدانا بالعمل على ماده تشبه الحجاره
وزيناها لتكون شبيهه بالرخام لدي خبره في
الرسم مكنتني من تطوير
[موسيقى]
مهارتي في مستودعات اللوفر نجد ايضا ورشات
حداده مهمتها خلق نظام متناغم لتعليق
اللوحات وعرضها لتقديم تجربه فريده وجديده
لزوار
المتحف علينا ال الفني على طريقتنا في
التعليق ان تكون خفيه وتبرز العمل فقط
الناس لا يرون سوى العمل النهائي وليس عدد
الساعات التي امضينا في انجازه انه عمل
مثير دقه هؤلاء التقنيين تساعدنا على
اكتشاف سحر العمل الفني ورؤيته من منظور
جديد متحف اللوفر يملك مجموعه مكونه من
9000 اطار بعضها معروض والبعض الاخر مخبا
في
المستودعات وتختلف انواع الاطارات
والبراويز وفقا لموضوعات اللوحات ومدارسها
وتضفي عليها قيمه
جماليه لذلك يعمل سته مختصين هنا على
[موسيقى]
صيانتها هنا لا نقوم بترميم الاطارات
ترميم
نرمم فقط مناطق التلف لكننا نحافظ على
التذهيب الاصلي لان الماده التي صنع منها
تحكي الكثير عن
تاريخه نريد ان نعطي انطباعا بان الاطار
تعتق على مهل وبان الزمن مر برفق وليس
دفعه
[موسيقى]
واحده خبرات مختلفه تتقاطع لتصنع متحف
اللوفر منذ ثمانيه
قرون